hey youtubers how's it goin we got
really awesome news about the DC
streaming service Titans Young Justice
season 3 premiere dates so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I'm
gonna play audio of an interview with
the DC community manager that's gonna be
managing this new streaming service
where she talks about the release date
the content that they're gonna be
putting on it in addition to Titans
Young Justice and the other live-action
shows like Swamp Thing so here we go so
I work at DC Comics sorry DC
entertainment and we are about to launch
I think late August our DC digital
platform o which will be a hub for all
things we see there will be digital
movies TV shows that you can watch
streaming we're gonna have a lot of
comics on there so there's gonna be a
lot of good there's gonna be a lot of
good stuff so you're doing original
video content so right now we are
working on getting everything from the
back catalog of like animated TV shows
and movies on there now that we will
also be producing I think right now we
have four in production original shows
yeah including Swamp Thing which a lot
of people are really excited about since
it's a horror title live-action yes
live-action I don't know I really like
this I like Swamp Thing from injustice -
I don't know anything about that I just
know swapping no idea that character is
as popular is it yeah I very excited
first one thing we have a couple of
other shows coming up too but that's the
one I hear buds about so I love that
movie in fact the villain is Louise your
dad friend my friend Derek gave me this
autographed birthday face and then look
at that Sean Connery
my friend tents yeah I would say if
you're a DC fan check it out I'm
community manager so I'm managing the
community so I will be DC Danny on the
boards yeah and I giving away giveaways
sweeps ace it should be fun that's great
congratulations that's exciting I look
forward to that I've always been a fan
of all of DC's entertainment so a couple
big takeaways when she says late August
launch I'm pinning that around the week
of August 20th they've already said that
Titans is gonna air all of its episodes
before they launch Young Justice season
three that would put Young Justice
season three thirteen to fourteen weeks
after that which is smack dab right in
the middle of November which lines up
with what the Young Justice season three
showrunner Greg Wiseman said said late
fourth quarter launch will that be like
the 12th or the 19th of November just
for comparison the arrowverse Batwoman
four-way crossover is happening the
first week in December just a week later
than it normally would in previous
seasons so you're basically getting the
Titans finale the beginning of Young
Justice season 3 and the big four-way
crossover all within a couple weeks of
each other really late in November the
other really cool thing that she talks
about is the other content that they're
planning on putting on this DC streaming
service so she said comics if you guys
have used Marvel unlimited before it
sounds like they're gonna be using this
as their DC version of Marvel unlimited
we've been asking for that for so long
comics movies and TV shows like pretty
standard video content for streaming
service Netflix style but she did say
that they were planning on launching
with almost the entire back catalogue of
TV and movie content so pretty much like
every TV show you could possibly imagine
including Batman and the animated series
Batman Beyond she talks about swampthing
like it's gonna be a genuine horror
title so it doesn't sound like it's
gonna be the Disney streaming service
where they focus mostly on
family-friendly content it'll have like
a spectrum of like really hardcore stuff
like Titans even Young Justice season 3
is supposed to be way more hardcore so
if you're looking for more hardcore
stuff than say like
DC TV on the CW this is really where
they're gonna be putting all that stuff
and in terms of price point
nobody has revealed what that actually
is they're probably still trying to
figure that out but it'll be cheaper
than Netflix and right now Netflix is
cheapest tier is $7.99 for their basic
service like you have to pay about 12
bucks to get the super HD 4k streaming
but it'll probably be somewhere between
$5.99 and $6.99 but in addition to that
cost that you're paying you get that DC
unlimited so you're getting a bunch of
comic books so you're saving money that
you would normally be spending on comic
books which are already $2.99 399 $4.99
like some comic books are getting pretty
expensive now but a lot of that's just
speculation so we can talk more about
price at Comic Con though so here's the
big thing they're probably gonna wait
till Comic Con to drop the trailer for
Titans and then announced their release
schedule like this is the exact day that
everything's gonna be dropping these are
the titles that we're going to be
launching with this is all the content
that you'll get on day one so they
haven't announced what their press tour
schedule is going to be but I'm guessing
that they'll start their press tour at
Comic Con which is the third weekend in
July and then for like that next four
weeks they'll be on the press tour for
Titans then at the end of that they'll
drop everything and launch the service
so if you follow major movie marketing
usually press tours are about four weeks
so when you get within about four weeks
of the release date that's really when
they start going all over the world
promoting the thing that's gonna be
launching so which will probably see
like Minka Kelly from Titans has been
posting a bunch of behind the scenes
pictures we got our first look at Jason
Todd I'll do a separate video about that
because all this news about them
launching in August with Titans and
Young Justice season 3 just happened
last night it is like the best news ever
so you'll probably see people posting
stuff from behind the scenes for the
next couple of weeks as we head into
comic-con like the closer we get you'll
probably see more and more stuff start
dropping the weird thing that she says
is she thinks that people are more
excited about the swampthing TV show but
if you heard about the Doom Patrol TV
show I've already done a couple videos
about that that might start shooting
this summer meaning the Doom Patrol will
be the next live-action show after
Titans but it might
not premiere till the spring of next
year or maybe the summer depending on
how long it takes him to film and they
might wait till after Young Justice
season 3 has aired all of its episodes
and there'll be 24 episodes of Young
Justice season 3 so that's many many
weeks of Young Justice before you see
another live-action show so what'll
happen is as we get more information
I'll do new videos but sometime in the
next couple of days I'll try to get that
Jason Todd Batman video out because we
got to look for what the bat symbol is
gonna look like on Titans but HBO just
confirmed what the first game of Thrones
prequel is going to be and when they're
gonna start filming it so I'll do a
video for that next emergency then I'll
do my cloak and dagger episode 1 video
that might not post till Saturday
because emergency Game of Thrones it's
freaking huge news so that should be up
in a couple hours we can freak out about
that so while you wait for everything
click here for brand new flash and click
here for all the big trailers that drop
this week thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight